ivan chagnaud propose voyage sans
passeport gabrielle bertrand et jean
naze se sont rendus en hassan pour
entrer en contact avec les peuplades de
race tibet en birmanie nous ont rapporté
des images
ils sont venus nous raconter leur voyage
gens nagent piazzale en assam voulez
vous nous expliquer où est exactement ça
mais la partie extrême orientale de
l'inde
elle se trouve au spi du tibet pied des
montagnes les maliennes à l'ouest
d'abidjan hma ni au nord du pakistan
oriental et là où sommes nous nous
sommes encore au billard nous dirigeons
vers la salle ceci est un petit temple
suivi
nous prenons un peu de repos voici le
camion la cheville ouvrière de
l'expédition
c'est elle qui nous a permis de
traverser ces passages si difficile vous
avez dû être embourbé dans des
conditions vous voyez les pénibles je
pense très souvent c'est pistes sont
beaucoup plus parcouru par des chars à
boeufs que par des engins motorisés
oui comme celle que nous venons de voir
pense exactement vous approchez du gang
du jeu du gange oui ce fleuve immense où
il n'y a ni pont ni aucun moyen de
transport pour le traverser
pourquoi n'y at il pas de pons est
impossible de construire là où il y en a
il y en a un qui est bien en amont
malheureusement il n'y a pas de route de
l'autre côté il est impossible d'en
faire une à cause des rivières qui
descendent de l'himalaya et qui
détruisent tout compliquer nous sommes
obligés de traverser donc sur une de ces
petites gens qu locales qui ne sont pas
très solides puisque la nôtre traquera
en cours de route et nous serons obligés
de faire un débarquement précipitez vous
étiez très lourd 4 tonnes en charge
c'est pas énorme de m oui mais le poids
est mal répartie sur quatre pneus
seulement ce qui représente sur deux
traversent le pont oui c'est fait masse
même endroit et il est large bande il
ferait environ 12 miles c'est à dire 15
à 16 km et nous devons le redescendre
sur près de quarante kilomètres pour
trouver la route de l'autre côté ceux
qui nous prendra environ 36 heures 40 km
36 heures a été très très vite
ce que je vois à la rame ouais bien sûr
nous y avons dû passer une nuit en cours
de route et le courant ne veut pas
porter non nous sommes là nous sommes à
gori pour c'est la première petite ville
de l'assam
nous nous sommes attendus par le
maharadja qui nous invitait dans son
palais c'est une ville tout temps plein
oui c'est une ville qui a été construite
du temps des anglais dont l'architecturé
est un peu bizarre oui
au fond de s'étaler cette porte cochère
et l'entrée du palais c'est un immense
plaît c'est un palais immense
effectivement mais il est très mal
entretenu maintenant depuis que les
rangers se sont vus privés de leurs
terres par le nouveau gouvernement est
bien celle diminuer considérablement
leur fortune et leur revenu je pense en
vie et ne peuvent plus entretenir ses
immenses palais et le fassent ce qu'ils
avaient autrefois cependant de temps en
temps quand même on trouve des jardins
avec des fleurs quelques années on s'est
entretenu notre à l'état sauvage qui est
aussi charmante mais nous avons en assam
à une période critique c'est la fin de
la mousson
les gens sont très heureux parce que la
mousson les a opprimés ils manifestent
leur joie par des danses une détente
c'est une détente et ces jeunes filles
vont être mariés dans l'hiver qui vient
puisque c'est lui baer la bonne période
la période sèche elle danse là avec
leurs demoiselles d'honneur elles sont
très jolies avec un soupçon d'un tambour
au son des tambours
citons vomir dans aussi les danses aussi
du temps la cadence c'est passionnant
qui la mesure mais je crois qu'il le
fait pour lui même surtout c'est une
tradition ou un usage
oui c'est parce que ces jeunes filles
vont être mariés dans l'année elle danse
ici avec leurs demoiselles d'honneur et
spontanément ça ne joue jamais appris
non ce ne sont pas des professionnels se
sont entraînés un peu la danse est
quelque chose de très en vogue chez les
indiens et toutes jeunes les jeunes
filles apprennent à danser extrêmement
précieuse et les vêtements qu'elles
portent sont tissés par elle-même dans
cette soin particulier à la sam qui
n'est pas faite avec le ver à soie mais
que l'on obtient un fallen d'un papillon
différents sites rue joly se disent tous
les verres au lieu d'être élevée sur le
mûrier sont élevées sur des feuilles de
riz sont c'est bien ils soient
extrêmement solide mais d'une couleur
très particulier avec les solides
voici une des futures mariées qui danse
avec ses demoiselles d'honneur
celle ci c'est tout à fait autre chose
et les mécontents ses parents veulent la
mariée un jeune homme qu'elle n'aime pas
alors qu'elle en aime un autre
elle vient faire cette danse devant le
radja pour lui demander d'intervenir
oui elle protestait ce qu'il le gagnera
elle a gagné leur a déjà mis quelques
pièces dans la corbeille de mariage et
tout s'est arrangé c'était une histoire
d'argent donc uniquement
et maintenant que font-elles ces
tendances différentes qui minent tous
les gestes qui ont lieu pendant la
culture du riz depuis les semailles leur
pic à l'arrachage des jeunes pousses
voyez arras le jeune pousse l hérault
pic ici et là et tous avec infiniment
danse
cj se sont également accompagnés de
juste religieux comme celui ci celui là
encore l'imposition des mains sur le sol
pour demander au génie de nouvelles
bonnes récoltes et pour les remercier de
la précédente
et maintenant à quoi correspondent ces
sortes de plumes au plumeau sont un
symbole ils représentent les gerbes de
riz les premières gerbes de riz qui
viennent d'être cueillis ils sont
emmenés en procession au village pour
être offertes au génie on les remercie
mais tout cela a un caractère
profondément religieux comme tous les
acteurs de la vie indienne d'ailleurs
ensuite le riz est coupée avec la
faucille ce passe en ce moment je pense
oui
et c'est le maître de ballet de vous
exactement
le pont
pas
et maintenant les jeunes filles vont
déposer du moins faire le geste de
déposer le riz dans le grenier grenier
étant représenté par le tambourinaires
je suis poli et voilà les vents qui vont
servir à vannes et et à trier le paddy
et ensuite le vit
quand je vois cette histoire du riz nous
est racontée oui vient ensuite les
pilonnages ne verront pas la cuisson
step difficile et maintenant nous
maintenant nous quittons gorille
pourrait nous partons sur le nord pour
atteindre les mais là c'est à dire des
grandes foires qui ont lieu au pied de
l'himalaya et qui sont fréquentées par
des buttes année il faut quelquefois bat
à 30 jours de marche pour atteindre ces
marchés ces foires si nous traversons
des tribus nous nous arrêtons pas
qu'elles ne sont pas pures
elles sont très mélangées elles ont pris
des coutumes un peu à gauche et à droite
cette femme par exemple à des boucles
d'oreilles népalaise tous les enfants
sont couverts de bijoux les gens ou les
bijoux sont très en vogue en au sam
il sent que kate
oui une porte ou frau
et voulait se montrer franchi la
frontière
non c'est un poteau qui indique que nous
allons traverser cette fois sur un bac
un petit bac à moteur on ne fait pas de
pont sur ces rivières parce qu'elle
descende nous sommes tout près de
l'himalaya et quelquefois le lit chances
de plusieurs kilomètres au moment de la
mousson serait donc dommage de faire des
ponts car l'année suivante on aurait un
pont sans rivière et une rivière sans
honte non passe très vite
oui c'est à dire des films que tu n'es
pas dans le comblement oui le premier
voyage voici les premiers petits chevaux
que nous trouverons et les derniers ce
sont des petits chevaux tibétains qui
sont venus avec les bhoutanais il parle
beaucoup il en bon karité ou au non ils
sont très très difficile
voici un boot année qui est absolument
étonné de voir un moine mendiants
chedjou qui gagne sa vie en récitant des
prières à longueur de journée voici un
autre avec une vache sacrée il exhibe et
500 ce qu'on dit lui très poussé qui les
oblige à prendre cette vie ou bien est
ce un moyen commode vivent aujourd'hui
nourrir
en principe je devrais être en mouvement
un sentiment religieux qui les pousse
mais je crois que et c'est d'ailleurs
l'avis de beaucoup d'indiens
c'est plutôt une bonne combine les
bhoutanais qui descendent sur ces
marchés viennent y chercher des épices
dont ils sont très privé et le sucre car
la canne à sucre ne pousse pas à la
haute montagne voici du sucre sous forme
de cassonade
c'est du sucre doit aussi un pâtissier
de sucre et de la farine
c'est nourrissant ce sens c'est très
nourrissant le bijoutier
oui de beaux bijoux d'argent martelé ou
ciselés qui sont fabriqués par des
hommes des tribus et voici des
bhoutanais qui achètent du coton car ils
tissent leurs vêtements eux mêmes et les
vêtements de la femme bhoutanaise et une
espèce de grande couverture dans
laquelle s'enveloppe qu'elle sert à la
taille par une ceinture qui forment une
poche sur la poitrine qui lui c'est en
quelque sorte de sac à main mais c'est
pas très très gracieux mais c'est
sûrement pratique ces pratiques
surtout lorsqu'elles doivent marcher
dans les montagnes sur les chemins
extrêmement pénible
si en pleine love c'est à dire un chef
de village je vois qu'ils ont la
coiffure porte la coiffure moderne c'est
probablement de jeu les bhoutanais que
nous l'avons rapporté non c'est possible
car c'est exactement ils font la coupe
au rasoir
oui et voici bout bush et les
stupéfiants
quand on pense qu'un bhoutanais ne se
lasse jamais de sa vie l'eau est sacrée
il n'y touche pas c'est assez terrible
de vivre auprès de hausse est impossible
pour un euro d'un buggy je vivais très
beau c'est de l'argent des montures
d'argent dans lesquels sont incrustés de
jolies pierres de la gamme des cornaline
du jeune et maintenant nous allons
quitter ses marchés pour aller beaucoup
plus à l'est
nous traversons une région qui vient
d'être complètement détruit par la
dernière recrue du brahmapoutre merci de
nous avoir accompagnés cette fois jean
nazet à la semaine prochaine nous
rendrons en votre compagnie auprès des
daf là il y avait une chagnaud vous a
proposé voyage sans passeport cette
émission a été réalisée avec le concours
de gabrielle bertrand de jean naze et de
solange pétait montage claude richard
son anniv et d'illustrations sonores
denise nazaire